das ist sehr gut so wunderschön sonnig
ist es ist viel passiert er in letzter
zeit bei mir und gerade deshalb ist die
lage gut hast du damit gerechnet
es hat sich im laufe der vorbereitung
auf das album langsam angedeutet dass es
weit nach oben gehen könnte aber ist
wirklich so weit nach oben geht hätte
keiner für möglich gehalten aber umso
schöner
wie hat sich das bedeutet dann merkt man
so was du merkst es einen klicks
natürlich dass du hast als erstes die
resonanz auf deine youtube-videos kannst
ein bisschen drunter lesen was die leute
so schreiben und wie die like
verhältnisse sind daumen hoch daumen
runter und dann kriegt man natürlich
auch feedback von der szene und von
leuten mit dem man zusammen arbeitet und
dann hat man irgend ein gutes gefühl und
als musiker selbst hat man ja auch
sowieso das musikalische gefühl dass das
was man gemacht hat dass es dass es cool
ankommen könnte das ist das ist richtig
dass verpackt was ich denke und das ist
gleichzeitig aber auch den hörer
irgendwie treffen kann kommt plötzlich
neue fans dazu genau wie leicht sich in
anderen sind als die alten fans für das
stader wird sich gerne bekriegt in den
kommentaren noch das ist großes
streitthema auch gerne denn denn die
alten fans sind natürlich nicht
begeistert davon dass jetzt kleine
mädchen meine songs posten auf facebook
und dann gibt es streit dann wird sich
und das ist herrlich ich gucke gerne zu
was da so passiert aber beobachter ich
höre mir dann vielleicht jetzt mein
aktuelles album in einem halben jahr mal
wieder an und freue mich darüber wie ich
das tor gemacht habe und ja dass man war
das schön war das schön du und dann
wieder gangsta rap ist das wenn du im
nachhinein dein album oder musik von
james ist das ein gefühl von
ja super passt alles ist alles aus einem
guss oder denkst du manchmal auch das
hätte ich jetzt doch anders aber jetzt
mit abstand trace anders mit abstand bin
ich eigentlich zunehmend zunehmend
wohlwollen damit mir selbst ich glaube
nach dem so ein album fertig ist ist man
darin ein wrack eigentlich man hat ja
alles raus gelassen und man hat ist
verzweifelt an einigen sie an einigen
stellen wirklich tatsächlich mit dem
kopf gegen die wand gelaufen und ich
manchmal sogar unsicher richtig und
weisheit macht man es halt einfach lässt
es so stehen und gibt es raus und fast
nicht mehr hat und fast das lieber nicht
mehr an um nicht noch mehr zu zerstören
und dann da muss es doch einfach mal gut
sein denn sonst würde nichts passieren
wenn ich ein perfektionist wäre dann
würde niemals was rauskommen
wahrscheinlich weil weil es alles nicht
gut genug wäre gar nicht vorstellen aber
ich lasse das dann gerne mal schwimmen
und wenn ich das dann mit dem abstand
der zeit wieder mal mir anschauen und
anhören dann dann funktioniert es besser
dann kann ich mich besser drauf
einlassen und auch besser sehen dass
alles doch einen großen sinn hat was
gesagt nach dem areal fertig hat ist man
einfach was passiert dann wird man bist
du krank oder wie äußert sich das
ich habe ja gar keine zeit krank zu
werden da muss es dann muss ja
weitergehen
video und fotos fürs cover und und und
und und die pressetermine wahrscheinlich
werde ich jetzt wenn dieser ganze
presserummel vorbei ist auch erst
wirklich zusammenbrechen weil es ja man
ist ja wrack im gedanklichen sinne im
ideen im kreativen sinne deswegen
deswegen gibt es halt auch phasen
schaffensphasen wo man wo einem partout
einfach nichts einfällt weil man ideen
ja nicht nicht einfach so fordern kann
also ich spiele sehr sehr selten
computerspiele aber wenn dann richtig
und dann richtig
und dann richtig wenn dann richtig heißt
tage wochen oder länger so eine nacht
vielleicht durch und dann reicht's auch
wieder okay und da kommt die ideen dann
bestenfalls kommen sie wieder wenn nicht
dann doch nur nacht